So in our last section, we talked a little about culture, language, and
thought. And now, we're going to jump to focusing on thought in more detail.
First we're going to begin by looking at thinking, reasoning, and decision
making, but there's a couple words you should know before we start. So, here,
we have "cognition". "Cognition" is the mental processes involved in acquiring,
processing, and storing knowledge. If you remember from lesson one, we talked
about cognitive psychology. Which is the study of how people perceive,
remember, think, and solve problems. When you're at home on the couch relaxing,
thinking about a vacation you want to take, or of the great movies you saw last
week, or even thinking about a new way to solve problems you may encounter.
What's happening? How are you able to do that? Did you ever stop to wonder
about what was going in in the brain? That is, how do we use our brains to
solve and maintain these mental processes? So thinking is our cognition.